un cese al fuego por 24 horas desde la
medianoche anunció el ejército de Sudán
como parte de un acuerdo humanitario que
permite ayudar a las personas atrapadas
en medio del conflicto que Se acude a la
nación africana
recibimos Una sugerencia presentada por
la ONU así como en comunicaciones con
países amigos y el secretario de
relaciones exteriores de los Estados
Unidos para tener un alto al fuego que
dure 24 horas hemos aceptado esto Solo
debido a la grave situación humanitaria
que viven los residentes de jartum donde
hay dificultades de movimiento los
hospitales y otros servicios como la
electricidad y el agua son escasos
tras cuatro días las condiciones de la
población son críticas los combatientes
han atacado a trabajadores humanitarios
y diplomáticos incluido el embajador de
la Unión Europea que fue agredido en su
casa Según la OMS las misiones médicas y
los hospitales se han visto gravemente
afectados
hay informes inquietantes sobre el
saqueo de algunas instalaciones de salud
y el uso de otras con fines militares
también Se informa que algunos
hospitales ya están cerrados o al borde
del cierre debido a los ataques y la
falta del personal médico y suministros
médicos
la pugna por el poder entre el ejército
de Sudán y los paramilitares de las
fuerzas de apoyo rápido Far estalló el
sábado el país se enfrentaba a una
transición civil que sería firmada a
principios de este mes donde los
miembros de las FARC entrarían a formar
parte de las fuerzas armadas regulares
tras cuatro años de derrocamiento del ex
dictador Omar al bachill y dos de un
golpe militar los combates afectan entre
otras a la región de darfur que desde
2003 sufre un conflicto interno que deja
unos 300.000 muertos y dos millones
700.000 desplazados